[Music]
Lorenzen Wright made headlines as the
seventh overall pick in the 1996 NBA
Draft he played for his hometown Memphis
Grizzlies and had a huge impact on that
community but in 2010 he mysteriously
disappeared police found his body ten
days later the case went cold for seven
years until new evidence led Memphis
police to make two arrests special
correspondent James Brown has a preview
of tomorrow's 48 hours at nearly seven
feet tall Lorenzen Wright was a giant in
his hometown first as a local high
school star then at the University of
Memphis and finally in the NBA with the
Memphis Grizzlies Lorenzen was the
hometown boy makes good former Memphis
police director Tony Armstrong says
Wright's impact was big you can imagine
with all of the lives that he had
touched not only here in this city but
all across the world it was a phenomenal
story by 2010 Wright was 34 years old
and at the end of a long NBA career
but then one night in July he suddenly
went missing this disturbing 9-1-1 call
was placed by Lorenzen Wright
[Applause]
tonight when one where's your emergency
nothing but gunshot but he was not able
to identify himself dispatchers say they
could not locate the source of the call
and no one made the connection he had
disappeared and he was gone over all of
these days and nobody knew anything this
is a broken investigative reporter April
Thompson covered the story for the
memphis CBS affiliate his mother Deborah
really kind of pushed that something's
not right we've checked all his friends
from here too a lot of Mississippi
everywhere so with I don't have a clue
ten days later the shocking news the
police found Wright's body near a
backwoods roads some 20 miles outside of
Memphis
he was shot five times this was Lorenzen
Wright who would be hating him that much
as Memphis mourned months turned into
years and the city became obsessed with
solving the murder of its favorite son
there was a lot of pressure to solve it
because of who Lorenzo right was you
know what he meant to this city then
finally seven long years after the
murder in November 2017 police got a
break they found the murder weapon in a
lake how unusual is it to find a key
piece of evidence some seven years later
they found a needle in haystack
weeks later police arrested two people a
landscaper with a criminal past and
Lorenzen Wright's ex-wife and the mother
of his seven children just the thought
of it is this an even real
James Brown is with us from Washington
JB good morning it's so shocking to hear
all of that and then that his wife was
arrested why do investigators think she
was involved and why she did it
shocking and sobering the story is
indeed noir and first of all Cheryl
right his ex-wife and Billy Ray Turner
the landscaper have both pled not guilty
now the prosecution alleges two things
one that she and the landscaper were
having an affair and second they alleged
that she killed Lorenzen right for the
million-dollar life-insurance policy
that he took out a short time before his
death Nora and how solid is the case
against her well keep in mind that this
was a cold case for quite a while as a
matter of fact seven years exactly so we
know that memories can be a little
sketchy over that period of time and
evidence maybe not as solid as they'd
like although there is more than one
suspect and often as you know Nora
the accused tend to point fingers at
each other so that always can present a
challenge still trying to think if she's
the ex-wife why she wanted him gone if
their marriage was done and done well
good question now Gail six living kids
seven kids they had total so one would
think it might have something to do with
the kids but with respect to that
million dollar life insurance policy
I'll say this much in promoting to the
story for tomorrow that million-dollar
life insurance policy was blown through
in about 10 months Gail JB thank you see
that's a good question will probably be
answered on Saturday night I'm sitting
there with my ex-wife hat on thinking
well what okay just wondering Gail Gail
please do not ever become a part of a
played out okay I will come visit you in
the slammer I could be a martial
enforcement yeah don't judge me here all
right you can watch his full report
Lorenzen right no defense tomorrow on 48
hours it airs at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS